Chris waters here with a gamespot news
update Activision has announced that
they will be spending five hundred
dollars on development and marketing for
destiny idols that can't be right hold
on a second what are we five hundred
million dollars on development and
marketing for destiny for perspective
James Cameron's Avatar costs about half
at the 500 mil will be used to cover
development marketing packaging
infrastructure support royalties and
more an Activision spokesperson
confirmed although they have big
differences in scope it's worth pointing
out that analysts estimate grand theft
auto 5 s total budget to be around 260
million dollars but while GTA 5 was a
single release destiny is planning to
unfold and evolved over a ten-year
period an Activision spokesperson also
explained that the company's investment
in the game's engine as well as quote
robust back-end infrastructure are
upfront costs that they expect should
help reduce future development costs no
matter how you look at it though 500
million is a huge sum to sink into an
untested IP and Activision is hoping to
at least double their investment they
intend for destiny to become their third
billion-dollar franchise after call of
duty and Skylanders Destiny's beta is
coming this summer first to PlayStation
systems the full game launches September
9 for xbox 360 xbox one playstation 3
and playstation 4 guess we'll find out
if that was money well-spent come
September 9th right here on gamespot